okay so good afternoon and welcome to
another of the Yale quantum institute
colloquia talks we're very glad today to
have Fred Chong visiting and he's been
here for a couple days and meeting with
people in variety departments
ECS Applied Physics and so on so fred is
the seymour goodman professor at the
computer science department at
university of chicago
fred is trained as a computer scientist
and as a computer architect but he's
been may be lured over to the quantum
side let's say and is doing more and
more quantum things these days he's the
lead investigator of a new 10
million-dollar NSF project in in the
division of computer science called epic
which is enabling practical scale
quantum computing with several
collaborators at Chicago and elsewhere
Fred got his PhD from MIT and was first
on the faculty at UC Davis then he spent
some time at UCSB from 2005 to 2015
before moving somewhat recently to
Chicago and he's won several different
awards his research interests span
computing quantum computing multi-core
and embedded architectures computers
security and sustainable computing and
you know I think we're very glad to have
Fred here some of us have known him for
a while and been chatting with him and
find more and more in the field of
quantum information that there's things
we can bridge between let's say hardware
and software and what Fred's gonna do
today is give us this talk which is
being recorded for future use on closing
the gap between quantum algorithms and
hardware using vertical integration and
code design so thanks a lot for coming
Fred it's been a wonderful visit and
we're looking forward to this and this
talk is sponsored by the quantum
Institute and also by the Department of
Electrical Engineering and computer
science so thanks thanks a lot so what
day today is I'm going to talk about
what we can do together computer
scientists and
to close what I'm going to describe as a
gap between the algorithms that we want
to run and the machines that we expect
to have in sort of the foreseeable
future and and this is the subject of
this large NSF project that we're just
starting which is called epic and and
it's it's and it's sort of that's a sort
of a microcosm of what we're trying to
do in which we have you know algorithms
people from MIT working with computer
scientists from UChicago with also some
technology people Dave Shuster at
UChicago and Ken Brown at Duke and and
many of the ideas that I'll talk about
today come from discussions with with
those team members all right so most of
you are probably somewhat familiar with
quantum computation but I just have to
do a couple slides of motivation you
know we're looking at this problem
because this is sort of an exciting time
for quantum computing and from sort of a
computational point of view you know
quantum computation is interesting
because it is sort of the only
technology that we know that can scale
computation potentially exponentially
with the number of devices that we build
and that can fundamentally change from a
computer science point of view what is
computable or tractable for computation
and that you know being able to solve
some of those intractable problems in
specific areas can be very interesting
for things like chemistry simulation and
optimization in particular in the near
term and you know practically that might
lead to a sort of impact such as you
know better materials better things like
photovoltaics
even better processes for things like
nitrogen fixation you know we're also
interested you know from in the
computing sort of industry and computing
world you know we have this phenomenon
where traditional CMOS scaling Moore's
law Dennard scaling those things are
sort of petering out a little bit for us
and so you know this has a potential of
giving us at least in very specific
instances a
to scale and accelerate things and also
studying quantum computation also
produce a sort of as a healthy
competition with classical computation
so you know the best way to get a lot of
classical algorithms people to work
harder on their algorithm is to have a
quantum algorithm it supposedly is
better right and that has in fact led to
interesting advances in the past so you
know we've been working on this problem
for a while and and I would say we've
been working on this problem from a
fairly theoretical point of view looking
at sort of very far future machines with
fairly perfect devices and lots of
devices but we're sort of into this
interesting time where in the next few
years we expect to see real machines
that you know are of non-trivial scale
and we've actually struggled a bit for a
while we've told you before a while to
figure out you know how do we
distinguish those sort of theoretical
ideal machines that we used to think
about with the ones that we're gonna be
thinking about for the next five to ten
years and john press kill has this nice
sort of term that we like which calls
the new noisy intermediate scale quantum
computer or Niska sounds a little bit
like risk computing and it's also
interesting that you know that that
denotes that we're sort of in this
privileged time where we you know really
might be able to demonstrate a
computation which is classically not
computable and that's one of our goals
in our project and you know here we see
some of the machines that have been
announced that are out there they're
mostly under test so we're still seeing
how well they're going to work but the
indications are that we're in a position
where we're gonna have you know maybe
100 cubits of some sort in the next five
years that we can do some computation on
right maybe more if we're lucky but even
with that sort of nice point in history
that we're at we have a fairly large gap
between the algorithms that we're
familiar with and the machines that we
expect so you know the algorithms that
are probably most well-known Shor's
algorithm for factorization and Grover's
algorithm really you're looking at
running on
like on a hundred thousand or a million
quantum bits right and this is for this
scaling graph is for trapped ions but
you know you see that there's sort of a
large gap of many orders of magnitude
between those sort of well-known
algorithms and the machines that we
might expect even going you know in ten
years into the future right so you know
we're sort of now in this regime where
in the algorithm space there is a lot
more attention to these sort of
near-term algorithms or heuristic
algorithms quantum simulation quantum
chemistry quantum approximate
optimization algorithm so these are
heuristics that basically minimize
energy right but you see that even these
they're still sort of a gap here and
that's sort of the point of what we
think we as a project and the community
we're trying to build we would we would
like to try to address and so we'd like
to address this sort of further gap with
this idea of sort of hardware software
code design right basically bringing the
software closer to a model of what
hardware really looks like from a
computer science point of view actually
breaking abstractions that make it
easier to write the software but make it
less efficient and so you know we have
the stack from algorithms down to
programming languages compilers
architecture some model of the devices
to the actual devices and this stack
historically has been sort of very
weakly connected right we actually have
the stack in some form for these ideal
devices but what we'd like to do is to
really look closely at this redesign it
for this near term or sort of a misc era
so we have this very aggressive goal you
know our goal is that we're gonna build
a stack and make the translation from
algorithms devices a hundred to a
thousand times better than it is right
now okay we actually think we could sort
of do this because the base line isn't
that great right now but mostly you know
these layers of abstraction make you
make it so that you do things very
inefficiently and what that does is
a factor of sort of a hundred to a
thousand would translate into some large
number of years of machine improvements
right so we're trying to do is shift
this intercept point well ideally in the
next five years you know in the lifetime
of our project but also ideally because
it's sort of some proof of concept that
this is an interesting thing to do would
be a good thing in the next five years
for the field in general just to be a
little more precise you know so I
plotted you know number of qubits which
is sort of the number you always see in
the press and when we announce machines
but more precisely we're really talking
about the space time product which is
essentially the number of qubits times
the number of gates right IBM would call
this the quantum volume and so if you
have a machine that has a two-bit GAE
error of ten to the minus three that
means that you can run one gate one bit
with a thousand gates all right
well sort of eight it's two qubit gates
but but you've got 32 bits right you
could only run 32 gates on each one
right or you could have a thousand
cubits and we're only run one gate on
each one so the volume is very can be
very restricted right and ideally I
think Google says you know they're
optimistically they'd like to get here
128 qubits thousand gates on each one
right and if we had that really then we
could probably do something interesting
on that machine right but the reason I
bring this up is because when I talk
about addressing this gap I talk about
increasing the efficiency both in terms
of how many qubits we use and how many
gates we use or sometimes even trading
those two off right so probably most of
you are somewhat familiar with this but
I'm just going to sort of establish a
baseline for those not familiar with
quantum computation you know when we
talk about a qubit we talk about some
sort of bit representation that is
implemented in some sort of quantum
physical device and we talk about a
superposition of zero
and one and we have this notation which
it uses these probability amplitudes and
every additional cubit that you add all
right doubles the number of states that
you're dealing with which is no
different than the classical case right
you can represent an exponential number
of states with every cubit or every bit
classical bit in the cubit space these
are potentially in super positions so
you have all of those possibilities
simultaneously right and what you're
doing is you're manipulating these
probability amplitudes such that you're
doing some sort of useful computation
and you know sir colloquially we might
call that quantum parallelism or some
form of parallelism which gives you an
exponential number of states to work
with which you know theoretically gives
you some computational power right but
the hard part is of course when you
measure this system collapses so it's
hard to come up with algorithms copses
to one state it's hard to come up with
algorithms that you do some useful
computation in some useful amount of
time right I'm often asked from sort of
domain scientists and people want to use
quantum computation you know what is a
good quantum application and sort of
there's some interesting implications of
you know how quantum computing works all
right the first one is that we we
generally have a bit of an i/o problem
right so input and output is fairly
expensive and in fact you you want to
put in a small amount of data in the
form of a few bits and have that become
an exponential amount of computation
right that's what a quantum computer is
good at right for example you'll often
hear you know the other popular buzzword
these days is big data everyone says
well can you put big data and quantum
computing together probably not because
if you had to put an exponential amount
of data into the machine then you won't
get any advantage doing the exponential
amount of computation right so you need
this sort of compact problem
representation and the examples that we
have are things like inverting at a
complex function modeling some small
molecules or small graphs doing
optimization on those things so those
are sort of high complexity computations
that come from a very compact problem
representation
we also because the the devices are
unreliable the algorithms tend to be
probabilistic we need an easily
verifiable solution typically you know
so Shor's algorithm is easy to verify
because you just multiply the two things
together and you see if that's the
product things like modeling the lowest
energy state of a molecule may be harder
to verify you may have experimental data
you may have the best-known classical
solution the other sort of interesting
thing that's happened in the last few
years is that we've come to a much
stronger reliance upon this model of a
classical quantum co-processing right
this is actually very helpful for our
situation so you can take sort of the
best known classical algorithm say for
modeling quantum chemistry and you run
that on the biggest classical
supercomputer you can find and you get
the best solution you can and then use
that to build the starting initial sort
of sauce or initial condition for the
quantum algorithm then you run that for
a very small time on your little quantum
computer and then you hope that it
improved the estimate and then you hand
it back to the classical one and you
just go back and forth right and and
this is actually gives us a very nice
situation because you know we're always
competing with the classical machines
but in this case we're starting from the
best classical solution so if there's
any improvement that can be had with
sort of the quantum sort algorithm and
model on a small machine then it gives
us a much better sort of chance of
improving of computing something that
wasn't computable before right and it's
also the case that we don't have a lot
of good quantum algorithms because
they're hard to come up with so we have
a small number of kernels sort of
algorithms that we have to exploit in
order to do anything you know sort of
computationally advantageous so what I'm
mostly going to talk about today is how
does the software model the hardware
there's also sort of the other direction
you know how can the hardware change to
be better for the software and we
have a sort of stack of tools which is
analogous to what we might in the
classical world called circuit synthesis
which is essentially going from some
high-level language like C and compiling
all the way down to hardware okay
so we do this in the classical world all
the time for either what are called
application-specific integrated circuits
or FPGAs and it's interesting because
the problem is more restricted and in
some ways easier or at least more
optimizable for quantum machines and
quantum alguns because we typically know
a lot about the program and the inputs
and the characteristics of what we're
trying to run because if they're very
small programs as you know we we might
compile a program specifically for
quantum chemistry to model a specific
molecule so that we basically know
everything about the program which
interestingly for us in the past meant
that the compiler quickly ran out of
compute and resources and memory
resources on a classical machine so we
we might even run the compiler on a
supercomputer basically so that because
we know so much about the program in the
classical case there are enough unknowns
that we sort of run out of things to
optimize in the quantum case since we
sort of know everything we can do all
kinds of classical compiler
optimizations to the nth degree okay
other things that are interesting you
know a little different from the
classical case we have to manage errors
and the precision we desire it's
actually less different than you would
think and I'll get back to this because
classical machines now that they're
often energy or power constrained are
starting to do this so classical
software tool chains already have this
capability so we can leverage those
techniques and of course we're sort of
in this interesting time you know which
is a little bit like the 1950s in
classical computing where resources are
super scarce right every bit and every
gate is is really scarce and so it was
interesting what I could give this talk
to all computer scientists I like to say
you know you ever you ever look at the
history of computer science and you
think if I was only alive and
1950s I would have written so many
papers and done so much stuff because it
was all new well that's where we are in
quantum computing right everything is
new right so this is a simple model that
we have for our software you can think
of quantum can the quantum commedia vice
is sort of like a coprocessor or like a
GPU essentially and so to us it sort of
looks like this right we have a
high-level language see like language
that we call scaffold it compiles to an
assembly language of basically quantum
gates and then that goes into a program
that sort of run concurrently on a
classical control processor and a
quantum coprocessor in the real case
this is probably a little more complex
but in terms of what the compiler thinks
of this is what it does and it's a lot
like you know you can pilot program for
GPU it's the same thing you sort of
decompose the program the classical
processor is controlling the GPU that's
true yeah so what so somewhere in here
there's something that produces
microwave pulses but the compiler thinks
of this as just sequencing all that
control so some sort of compute power
that does that and then somewhere like
it along this boundary is the low-level
control so in fact our compiler actually
doesn't produce the pulses but we then
feed into some other toolset like IBM's
quiz kit or actually Dave Shuster has
his his set of control software so so we
basically just feed into somebody else's
control so although we are changing that
so one of the ways to make things more
efficient is to to not have that
boundary to sort of directly create
pulses for example so this is very too
much about the details this is actually
what our toolchain currently looks like
it's 40,000 lines of code it's open
source and but and it's sort of neat
because it uses this like very
well-established
compiler technology called LLVM which is
open source library from Illinois and a
lot of sort of real compilers have been
written with this infrastructure and
what did
does is it it does a whole bunch of
optimizations pass by pass right so it
does the one at a time that's to control
complexity that actually isn't optimal
because something you do here might
affect something you do over there and
you might have to go back around so one
of the things that will make this more
efficient as sort of collapsing some of
these layers in the past we were
compiling for programs that were say for
a million cubits or something like that
and we had to do this in order to make
the computation manageable for each of
these layers but if we're only compiling
for 100 cubits or small program we might
be able to collapse a lot of this which
is something we're going to be doing
this it's I sort of this is broken up
into sort of the logical part which
assumes sort of perfect gates at qubits
and then then it goes to some physical
stuff which it like maps the data to
specific physical locations schedule
things introduces error correction
worries about communication things like
that so this is what we have we're after
gonna be spending a significant amount
of effort in the next five years
retargeting being this approach and this
infrastructure from you know ideal giant
machine to noisy little machine yes so
it doesn't run anything it exists
because it was it was written for the
IRP quantum computer science project or
a program and what it does is it does
resource estimation so it counts the
number of qubits and the number of
cycles it would take to run on a
hypothetical machine and it allows you
to do the optimization zhan these large
programs and sort of look at the effect
of those optimizations so this is sort
of for example what that compiler would
do it did a whole bunch of sort of
traditional compiler optimizations takes
you know loops and unrolls them into
lots of instructions and all kinds of
sort of traditional things
optimizing code that are going to run
the classical machine it is you can
think of it as pretty much the quantum
machine I mean the classical machine all
it's doing is keeping track of the
ordering and the parallelism essentially
so so this this like the scheduling all
the operations we focus on the quantum
part okay and then this just sort of
shows you for a set of things like
Grover's algorithm and Shor's algorithm
the compilers able to expose a lot of
parallelism so what these bars are is we
have more and more quantum bits you know
how much faster is the thing because the
sort of traditional speed-up graph and
and so this you know these things work
but now we're gonna try to do a lot
better and what I'm going to do and the
rest of the talk is talk about what are
the kinds of things we're going to need
to do to target you know sort of
realistic machines okay so it's a little
bit of a grab bag of things so this is a
paper from the Delft group very recently
end of last year 2017 it actually it's a
microarchitecture for a pseudo real
machine right so you know for say a
quantum dot machine and it actually won
best paper which is sort of amazing that
architects decided that quantum
computing mattered probably because I
got to vote but I was on the best paper
committee but this the sort of the most
interesting thing about this is that
it's a very traditional architecture
it's a it's a micro coded machine so
it's just like lots of old classical
machines and what it the interesting
part of it is has this little boundary
here where it queues up micro
instructions so that it can play them
back and there will be no gaps in the
microwave pulses essentially so it sits
as a synchronous asynchronous boundary
and so that was sort of the innovation
of this little architecture it was that
it identified the fact that I had to run
a whole bunch us figure out a whole
bunch of stuff queue it up and then
play it back at a speed that the the
quantum control wanted it to come come
at basically so so one best paper but
it's not without shortcomings so I would
say that this traditional approach and
our traditional software stack is
probably leaving too much on the table
in terms of optimization okay and I'm
gonna give you an example of some work
that I'm doing with Dave Schuster which
showed you why you should break this
abstraction at for example architecture
wise okay so so this is a instruction
set architecture you know so that that
thing had a really strict instruction of
that architecture so here's a place
where we might not want to do that so
our compiler takes C code and compiles
it down to two qubit gates which are
essentially our instructions okay and
then those two qubit gates are turned
into week and them to somebod some other
software that turns out it to microwave
pulses right so here's the thing that we
can do instead of taking two qubit gates
in this set of results which are sort of
preliminary we go up to five qubit gates
right and what you can see is if we can
directly generate control pulses for
five qubit gates it takes less time
right and so this is sequence length
this sort of rough measure of number of
pulses in time and we get about a factor
of two improvement in the sort of number
of pulses that we need achieve the five
qubit gate if we did it directly versus
a whole bunch of two qubit gates all
right and then this this is for a QA o a
so the optimization algorithm and the
two red lines are for different parts of
the circuit the best and the worst
advantage that we got and the blue lines
the average of for the whole day okay so
this actually I think is we expect to
get a lot better for one we could
probably build this take this out to ten
cubits and another is this actually the
first set of results is very simplistic
and assumes global interconnect and so
if we went to modeling the IBM machine
with a 2d mesh or something it's going
to have a lot of swap gates and as
they're going to take a lot of time
and it turns out that this approach is
really good at combining swap gates with
other gates right so we're gonna get a
pretty big advantage here I think and
remember we wanted a factor of a hundred
to a thousand ads you know so we need a
lot of factors of ten or five or
something like that right
but this is one of them and what this
does is it totally breaks several layers
of our software right so instead of you
know dealing with instructions we have
to at some point start emitting just
basically Big Unit Aries and then
handing them to this optimal control so
gradient descent optimizer essentially
this is also very computationally
expensive in order to push this to ten
cubits and to look for good sequences
we're probably gonna put this on a giant
supercomputer so you're gonna use lots
of memory and search lots of sequences
here's another interesting thing it is
it is it that's right that's right it's
it is an exponentially complex thing and
so we are sort of brute-forcing it as
far well not really we're doing some
gradient descent and we're doing it as
best we can
ironically QA Oh a essentially death
gradient descent a sort of so we could
use q aoa to optimize q aoa but you know
there's a lot of these things are a
little circular computer scientists love
this they're like but why don't use the
quantum computer to do that you know and
and and that that is probably not
something we're gonna do in the next
five years but maybe ten years from now
we'll be doing that right so like one of
the things we're gonna be looking at is
verification and everyone's sort of
saying oh well fair cake verification is
really hard you should really use
quantum computer to do verification yeah
of course assuming that the quantum
computer was already verified and works
right so yeah another interesting thing
that we've been looking at it may not
immediate or interviews because sort of
novel and exciting it but I mean
I'm a quantum computing way to view it's
actually pretty simple right so when we
compile these programs we use a lot of
ancilla
or scratch bits right and a big sort of
culprit of that is something like you
know we generate a lot of reversible
arithmetic and you know instead of you
know we start out essentially with NAND
gates right and then we have to produce
reversible gates and the smallest sort
of reversible gate is 3 to put 3 out and
so compared to 2 input one out there are
a lot of scratch bits there right so you
have all these scratch bits and it turns
out well we could reuse them but we can
only reuse them if we actually
uncomputable
so there's a direct trade-off between
the number of bits we use and the amount
of computation we do we do extra
computation to get bits back and so we
can either do the computation at the end
or which doesn't really help us but we
do it as we go or with some frequency
essentially so the more computation we
do the fewer bits that we use ok and so
this is sort of our what we call quantum
memory management right and so here's a
here are a few applications that are
once again so a lot of our results are
for big applications so we have yet to
see how well these will work for small
applications right because this is our
old infrastructure so in the old
infrastructure we can see that we can
save a lot of qubits that's the read so
that's a fraction of qubits that we can
reuse so we no longer need that many
qubits so we get a very up yuto's over
75% qubit reuse in this boolean formula
algorithm and not so good in this binary
welded tree and this is like a Grover's
that inverts sha-1 so and this is how
much compute we need extra compute it's
an extra number of gates that we need to
get that savings ok and so remember what
I told you was what's important is the
space-time volume right so we just
multiply these two graphs together I get
this right and what you see is for this
guy here it was not worthwhile right the
space-time volume is
bigger than what it was before but for
this guy here actually it's pretty good
right so it's up greater than factor of
two improvement in space-time volume
right so that's a this is another
technique that we sort of and ice this
is the extreme case we can actually
uncomputable errs actually have to make
gonna make a decision as to how much of
this to do i had this organized this way
because like the first one is like an
architecture problem the second one is
like a OS ish problem or memory manager
problem I gave a talk at a place called
S Plus which is architecture OS
approving programming languages ok so
here is an interesting problem that
whenever we want to go from a sort of
ideal machine to a physical machine we
actually have to figure out where does
the data go right physically and we want
to minimize how far apart the data is
and you know as and if machines get
bigger and for example our modular and
clustered in some way that we have to
worry about how much communication there
is between as we get further and further
apart this is a very traditional problem
in classical parallel computing and in
even classical chip layout ok and we use
things called graph partitions right
these these use the spectral zero
eigenvalue methods which basically
minimize find the min cut of things and
so this is a spectral community
algorithm and so this is a hierarchical
algorithm for for magic States and it's
sort of tree based and you can see that
we can the the the partition err can
find some nice groups right and so if
you if you map these on to clusters for
example then you can see that the lot of
edges inside they're not so many between
there right and so that's that's a very
traditional thing to do it's a little
bit interesting it's complex because
this kind of approach is very nice
because it it it computes a global
optimum of some sort it's just hearest
ik but it but it takes advantage of lots
of global information as to what the
graph looks like but it tends to be
static so what that means is say we take
a function and we look at the graph for
a function or
I'm part of a circuit and we come up
with a good mapping for it but within
that circuit it could be that you know
maybe the data could move somewhere or
that the mapping doesn't have to be
static and there's a so at Intel they
have a recent paper where they used
totally greedy dynamic approach right
and it works well for small machines but
there's some trade-off between how
dynamic you want it and how globally
optimal you want it right so the greedy
approaches don't know anything about the
global optimum the global approaches
don't know anything about how things
change right you can get something
between that with granularity which is
like you take a circuit or function you
break it up into time steps and you have
a different mapping for each one but
then you have to minimize the amount of
shuffling around between mappings or
else it'll cost you right so that's
something we're looking at there's a
sort of weird complexity also like the
last thing I showed you which is qubits
can be reused okay
but when they're reuse that means they
suddenly appear somewhere in the circuit
and then they have to when the next time
it's where they're being used they have
to move over to that place right and so
the mapping actually is now affected by
this dynamic more dynamic reuse thing
right and so it's just sort of I don't
know layers and layers of complexity and
what you can optimize but that that is
another thing we need to consider all
right here's another one that's sort of
at a lower level you know for you know
in computer science one of the you know
other big buzzwords is machine learning
right and you know there are some
interesting techniques that people have
used to adapt to for example device
behavior they're also sort of
interesting techniques here so at IBM
they were they've been doing some just
sort of very simple statistical
differencing of things right they run
this a circuit at different gate times
and expose different gate noise orders
of gate noise and they subtract that out
and so they get some really nice sort of
better Fidelity's just by repeatedly
running the circuit as opposed to
changing their machine in any way what I
find interesting here actually is is
a lot of these machine learning
approaches aren't so practical because
they require a lot of training data and
retraining and so one of the things that
we've done for classical computing
systems is use a combination of machine
learning and control algorithms to
dynamically adapt to varying system
behavior without having to retrain right
and so I think there's hopefully some
leverage to be had in that kind of
combination all right so now we get into
sort of the funny part of this so we're
in this sort of ridiculous bootstrapping
situation right where you know we write
code we have this compiler 40,000 lines
of code we have application code we
basically never run it on anything
because we don't have a machine that's
big enough we don't have simulators that
are big enough right and so we're in
this situation where you know if I if I
took my code tomorrow and I ran it on
you know the 50 cubed IBM machine and
obviously it wouldn't work I wouldn't
actually know which errors came from the
software and which errors came from the
hardware right and so this is actually
sort of for us a large part of our
project is this issue of formally
verifying that the implementation of the
algorithm is correct and the and the
implication of the compiler and its
optimizations are correct right we in
the past have not had any of this stuff
actually we were you know so asked to
make the compiler but never asked to do
this and I think it's a really important
thing and it's it's a very interesting
you know so there's a lot of this
technology in computer science typically
it's not used that much in industry or
in practice but here we have like really
strong motivation to use that right and
there's also very interesting sort of
theoretical fundamental question here
which is what we'd really like to do is
come up with some way of checking
programs that isn't exponentially
complex but we still want the program to
have exponential computer computing
power right so if we
actually you know our MIT collaborators
really like this problem because they're
actually perfectly happy to have
negative results so they're like well if
we simulate this that means that we've
proven that this isn't dust has no
quantum supremacy right so that that's
interesting to them from a sort of a
practical point of view what we would
really like to find is some way of of
checking some restricted properties or
partial computations that is either
polynomial in time to check or maybe
just exponential but with a smaller
exponential than the the actual
computation right and and and that's you
know something that we're trying to
explore right now and now part of that
comes in other efforts that that that
are related you know one effort that's
related is just making the biggest
quantum simulator you can write this
sort of typically noise free simulation
but so you know we have this like 45
qubit simulator that ran on some do-e
giant supercomputer and then you have a
few of these results for restricted
simulations like random shallow circuits
where they use a tensor contraction to
optimize the order in which you simulate
Tezz so that you use less memory and
fewer operations so they could get to 49
there this is a very interesting area of
research I have a student going up off
to Argonne to sort of do HPC high
performance computing tricks to you know
make this 49 or something like that
right you know just use the biggest
machine do memory compression and all
kinds of crazy stuff and make this push
this up it's an exponentially difficult
problem so it's only so far we could go
but what's interesting about this is
this defines the line between classical
and quantum right so you're going to
build a machine and you want it to be
more powerful than a classical machine
it has to be more powerful than this
thing right and so this blind keeps
moving a little bit you know we're
probably pretty safe at 100 cubits I
mean right now get there but but you
know the funny thing about this right
the Google machine used to have the
target of 50 cubits and then this is
like IBM when it came and wrote this
paper 49 and just to maybe stick it to
them and then they're like oh so then
they're like 72 yes you know right
I mean is this comparison because that's
right this yeah so yes that is unfair
that that is unfair yeah you're right
you know like so you really should have
more qubits that are perfect right so
but it's so yeah it's just a sort of a
rough guide this is a very interesting
line between classical and quantum right
in fact here's an interesting result you
can simulate right any quantum circuit
with only Clifford gates in polynomial
time right and so we know that in order
to have a good quantum algorithm that's
more powerful than a classical algorithm
it has to have more than Clifford gates
and in fact you can simulate a small
number of T gates also in polynomial
time and so there's that boundary is
some squishy boundary between you know
how many peak eighths do you mean before
it's like naught this is more powerful
than classical and so you know this is
something we're sort of exploring even
just to test programs right it's like we
can test small parts of our programs
that are simulate able and in fact we
have this sort of idea which is sort of
interesting which is if you know the
inputs and outputs of a specific
instance of a quantum program or circuit
we might be able to constrain the
simulation to be polynomial which
basically from in a classical world that
means we can in polynomial time do one
software test vector right so
input/output pair and then it becomes a
testing problem where you have to pick
test vectors that sort of exercise the
program right so that's sort of a
methodology we're trying to develop so
that's also related to this other piece
of the software puzzle which is that so
the sort of holy grail of programming
language and software people is that if
we only wrote a better program languages
better tools than the quantum algorithms
people we
come up with a lot more cool quantum
algorithms right and so if you talk to
quantum algorithms people they would say
no way it's not how we do it right but
it is the case that in our experience
implementing a quantum algorithm is
really difficult so let's say that
someone wrote a paper that says here's
linear systems algorithm or something
takes like a year and a half to write
that algorithm for real on a machine
right it's like we're implementing all
this stuff and there's a little there
are a lot of errors both semantic and
sort of performance problems and so this
is a there lots of a lot of detail there
and in that specific task I think there
is a big role for software tools better
languages better feedback debuggers we
don't have debuggers you know so
software tools that can help us write
good implementations of algorithms and
so you know some of that's visualization
maybe some of that is maybe breaking up
algorithms into libraries or templates
so that you could people applications
programmers can easily use those and so
I'm going to talk a little bit about
visualizing some properties and
something called program synthesis just
as examples so here is a time varying
graph of every qubit in a linear systems
implementation for different essentially
parts of the circuit okay and on the
y-axis is the sort of the fraction of
those qubits that are entangled with
each other so it's basically how much
communication or how much sort of what's
the relationship between those qubits
and sort of the higher the fraction the
harder it is to simulate the machine and
the harder it is to build a machine that
can a physical machine that could
support that communication essentially
and I'm sort of interested in seeing you
know what's the fraction really and it
actually is a little bit lower than I
expected
right it can't be trivial it can't be
too low or else there's probably there's
no computational advantage to the
algorithm but it's not quite as high as
I thought it might be and so this is
something that we might want to
understand better because this helps us
in mapping the algorithms it helps us in
understanding how to simulate them and
it also helps us in understanding if you
wrote an algorithm and this doesn't look
right that might show you that you know
you didn't implement it correctly for
example so really one sort of final
further afield thing is there is this
technique in classical computing which
has recently become popular in the last
few years called program synthesis and
program synthesis is this sort of
interesting technique where you you
sketch the program so you write some
specification program that's not an
implementation it's incomplete
it's it can be sort of partial and this
thing called the synthesizer essentially
exhaustively searches for all the
implementations that meet the skeleton
or the sketch and then this thing called
the verifier checks to see if it's a
correct implementation so you have to
have a some way of checking to see if
the program does what you want it to do
right and then sort of just goes around
and then out comes some programs this
technique actually has been used to
create things like Network protocols for
networking security policies for
implementing different secure computing
systems so when you have a restricted
domain a restricted problem and maybe a
special language domain-specific
language then they can do this
reasonably well and you might imagine
that quantum circuits quantum computing
is a sort of restricted area that we
might be able to apply this so we're
just starting this here's sort of a
little hand example that of one of my
students played with so he sketched
quantum teleportation and then he by
hand he didn't have an implementation
exhaustively searched all the things
within his sketch right and the
interesting thing is he came up with
this little protocol which like no human
would come up with right and and it's
not clear it's useful I mean so his
particular there are two benefits of
this number one he's interested in
coming up with interesting variants
interesting implement
of different algorithms maybe they'll be
useful for something we don't know yet
I'm actually interested in just a
correct synthesis path like so we have
an algorithm and we create an inflation
and we know it's correct right that in
this case that might be easier than what
the situation we have right now which is
we have an algorithm that someone
implemented by hand and we don't know if
it's correct and even if we had a
specification of if it's of what it
should do it's very hard to check those
two things together all right so
basically check and implementation
against a specification there are ways
of doing that that's we are actually
doing that too but in this case the
forward sort of synthetic path might be
easier than the checking path to see if
something is correct all right so let me
wrap up this really comes down to what
are the right abstractions okay
so right now we have all these layers
and the state-of-the-art right now is
you know we don't have much in the waste
specification or formal methods but
there are you know there's a formal
language called cook which does allows
you to prove things about programs if
you write them in that language we might
you know Express algorithms in terms of
the properties of the Hamiltonian and
then we can check that against some
implementation or it may be synthesize
some implication and right now we have
all these little programming languages
that exist out there they each have
their strengths and weaknesses and then
they mostly all go down to some form of
gates or quantum assembly which now you
know so IBM is is has a standard being
called open chasm it's a variant
actually we came up with chasm like 15
years ago
you're not with Ickes group and it's
sort of our fault that we didn't impose
any control on it because everyone has
their own flavor of chasm actually but
now we're trying to you know standardize
it and then you know actually there even
IBM is even thinking of coming up with
the Czar's a pulse control interface so
that if we have these layers of software
we could sort of target different
machines with some abstraction of what
pulsus look like so this is sort of
maybe this what it where we are now a
lot of what I talked about today is sort
of breaking this right you know going
directly from here to here for example
right and so you know that's something
that we are going to explore over the
next five years or longer and think
about you know where where must we if we
want efficiency break abstraction and
where can we you know where where can we
leave it in place right and that really
comes down to this sort of interesting
question which is you know I talked
about this gap between algorithms and
devices right and filling this gap well
there's this other sort of weird gap
that we deal with now all the time
because we've done fifteen years of work
where we were on this end and now we're
on this end and in fact it's sort of
awkward cousin like you know when I
write a paper I have to say this is
about this side and then sometimes I
would still write something like this
like oh no this is about this side and
then the question is over time how are
these things going to relate to each
other right we did all these sort of
short-term tricks right we're gonna do
how many of them were persist as we
scale the number of qubits
optimistically to the right right and
you know in in classical computing this
happened right in the 50s we were here
and as we got to play over here we
started ignoring things like physical
properties we started ignoring things
like well we don't care how many bits we
use right will we ever get there that's
not clear in the classical in the
quantum space also the classical space
is moving back this way because of
energy constraints we are starting to
worry about no easy computation with
approximate computation so we're sort of
breaking that abstraction even in the
classical space so I actually feel like
we're probably going it up somewhere in
the middle here I mean I know how many
bits it's going to be but we're gonna
have some mixture of the things we learn
in the next five to ten years and some
mixture of the things we had before
right so I'll just say well
strapped up with you know one of the
things that we're doing is sort of
community building so we they're very
few computer scientists or computers
other than theorists in this field and
they're basically just a few of us on
this team and so we're trying to like
greatly increase that and and as part of
that we're creating a whole set of tools
that go from our tools to the IBM tools
down to their machines and then sort of
educational materials and examples of
these research problems right and it's
geared towards you know computer
scientists but you know in general this
might be useful to the community as a
whole it should be nicely packaged this
is our project website we keep it all
there and so as we've developed this
well it's all going to be open source
and released and it'll be like yeah
Jupiter notebooks and videos and all
that stuff and in and and this website
actually as a whole you know we have a
an umbrella which is like going to be an
industry consortium and and probably an
academic consortium since there's
actually a hundred people are registered
for this thing right now so so that
community as we build it will try to
sort of nurture forward and and provide
tools and and guidance and
collaborations as we go so you know
where are we right so you know I think
it's an exciting time right it's a
historic time or we hope it's a historic
time right and I think that you know it
is is there's this big missing piece
which is this middle the software and
the architecture and that it's going to
be a really key part of accelerating
progress in the field right and I think
that you know what we're really looking
for a sort of like the right models and
it's abstract shion's to sort of get the
maximal leverage at this point and maybe
into the future so that's it thank you
very much
[Applause]
so for quantum computing this actually a
lots of effort will be spent on doing
error correction and meant being for
tolerant against the errors and can
comment down how this like a software
thing could actually make that putt be
even more efficient so do you mean error
correction in the traditional sense or
maybe I should repeat that right okay so
do you mean error correction in the
traditional sense or like like the error
correction we talked about like errors
Oh continuous aircraft motivational
engine more traditional right so
actually in the next five years we are
not focusing very much on error
correction because we don't expect to
have the resources to do that so we're
focusing actually on what we would call
error mitigation so any kind of very
lightweight redundancy some of our team
members are sort of at the algorithms
and sort of applications or chemistry
level and so they're looking at sort of
application specific methods you know
sort of redundant sampling or does a
little bit of redundancy in the data
structures so you know we're we can
probably probably only afford like
factor of two redundancy not like a
factor of twenty or so or thirty right
and so that's that's our focus in the
near term it's still the case that we're
hosts it's funny my students they just
keep going they like we're always
tempted to do more work on the
right-half because we you know have all
this infrastructure and still have ideas
so they just wrote another paper on like
surface code decoders or something I'm
like but that's like a lot of qubit so
anyway our you know our project norm
nominally is targeting a hundred to a
thousand cubits and the Rilke okay maybe
thousand cubits you know I think we'll
still put the project name on it or
something but but I think it but our
focus our emphasis is is going to be not
those those
I'd like to ask one so I like the
discussion about quantum volume but you
also had this slide we were showing some
metric that went by a little too fast
not me the degree of entanglement
between oh yes certain qubits it seems
to me like maybe you know quantum volume
if you just do it in a very
straightforward way you might have
almost no entanglement I mean you could
have many many gates you know but if you
if you if you started all on the ground
stae and just start doing things nothing
much is gonna happen right all right so
and there's this also this thing you
talked about with the number of T gates
somehow mattering so right is there a
way to efficiently compute something
about the not just the sort of
straightforward volume from the
space-time area but the effective
interesting part of Hilbert space volume
the degree of entanglement times number
of qubits right and and maybe how does
that algorithm or that metric you showed
relate to this yeah so I think that
would relate in the sense that well so
as a software tools person the way I
would calculate the sort of the more
realistic quantum volume is I would just
run it through the tool chain for a
specific application right and I could
scale it out for any architecture and
sort of it have an automated metric
that's applicant specific to the to the
connectivity of an application and
specific to whatever machine that you
have now most often we want some sort of
analytic thing that's very abstract
right and so number of qubits is
abstract qubits times gates is abstract
IBM actually defines quantum volume as
number of as the volume that you can get
with a random circuit right which is a
very demanding actually concept set of
connectivity right because most circuits
probably have some locality random
Serkis have all these global connections
so that's a very hard metric that they
use I mean I would probably use
something that was maybe a benchmark set
of programs program graphs
and then you know we could calculate the
volume for all those graphs and maybe
take an average or some have some
statistics on that
that would be maybe some compromise
between the really simple thing and the
very sort of having to have the software
tools to calculate it for you also be
interesting to the computer science
people so you know just from brief
interactions with various computer
science people they they learn different
math than we learned and they you know
they they have a very different you know
quantitative background so do you have
you've now developed an educational
bridging type of curriculum or bootcamp
or process for saying how much quantum
and what kind of quantum do I teach
people who think of themselves as
primarily computer scientists you know
applied mathematicians so shall we say I
mean so you tell us how you were
addressing that yeah that's a really
interesting question I mean I'm not sure
we have the answer yet although it is
one of our charters as NSF cares about
this kind of thing and there are a
number of people working on this problem
also you know from different
organizations I mean I think the problem
is actually computer scientists vary
quite a lot right you know even within
computer science you know you could
teach people about quantum computing
from sort of a linear algebra point of
view which is already abstracting away a
lot of the noise and device models but
then that's even just a subset of
computer scientists because then a lot
of computer scientists might like you
too so in I I'm in the architecture
community and architects tend to think
of things as circuits and you know
graphs and things like that but not so
much like you can teach it to them in
linear out with linear algebra but they
won't get any intuition out of it
actually that's sort of actually the way
I am like
I understand how things work but it
doesn't like someone has I have to like
reduce it to like an architecture or a
graph or you know some set of costs and
circuits or something like that
and so so I usually we usually teach
things that way like this we mostly
teach things to architects right like so
we come up with some abstraction we come
up with some parameters for devices and
components and then we sort of show how
that composes and so it it looks like
you know a fairly abstract like abstract
or like reductionist view of how
machines are built with some very you
know sort of relatively unexplained
rules like oh well these two things are
related we won't really explain how but
you know they are and then or maybe
there's some error mode between these
things so we that's right I think that
that is typically how we start you know
in our research is a little different
because right now we're having to look
more closely at machines so our specific
students oftentimes have some background
you know if in multiple degrees and
things like that so they they they can
it's but we're I mean we're the group at
the boundary right but I sort of imagine
a lot of groups that we want to get
involved in this are going to be far
above the boundary essentially I mean it
is it is also case like so at Chicago we
have this thing called the Institute for
molecular engineering and they have like
a quantum engineering degree program and
they're actually trying to abstract this
away or not come up with a methodology
that's gonna be much closer to teaching
how physics and devices work for
engineering students right but not
necessarily physics students okay I
think maybe in the interest of time they
see there's a few more questions but
maybe we should sort of wrap up here so
I think it's very interesting talk
you've given us and I really am glad to
see that you are working in this kind of
area I mean I think I agree
wholeheartedly about this being a very
interesting time and if we're gonna make
quantum computers useful it's not going
to be just a hardware problem or a
software problem it's definitely going
to take the combination of both so
thanks for sort of setting the table and
okay
[Applause]
[Music]